she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
well it looks like kanye west still has
his eyes
set on the white house on sunday the
rapper held his first political rally
where he got emotional talking about his
platform
and his stance against abortion and now
a source tells e.t
his wife kim kardashian is not happy
about it
here's what you need to know kanye spoke
to a crowd in
south carolina and said if he were
elected president
he would fight to keep abortion legal
but would strongly discourage it by
offering people
one million dollars for every child they
have the opportunity to be given a
million dollars
just for being pregnant which you have
considered
and that everybody would start making
children the greatest gift of life
the fashion mogul teared up saying that
his own dad wanted his mom to have an
abortion
when she was pregnant with him my mom
saved my life my dad wanted to avoid me
my mom saved my life there would have
been no kanye west
because my dad was too busy
then the 43 year old said he considered
an abortion when
kim was pregnant with their first child
daughter north
who is now seven of course the couple
now has four
children together i said we're gonna
have this
child i know people that are 50 years
old
that didn't have the children that
didn't have that child
that have never got to experience the
look eat
the level of joy that i experienced from
having a child
so even if my wife were to divorce me
after this speech
she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
she stood up and she protected that
child e.t has reached out to kanye's rep
for comment
but now a source tells et that kanye's
family and friends
are worried about him adding that kim is
upset over the rant
especially his comments about their
daughter quote she knows this is
something north will see when she gets
older
and that's heartbreaking kanye's
bombshell confession comes
after reports claim that the rapper is
in the midst of a bipolar episode
and our source says quote kanye isn't
in a good place and isn't listening to
anyone trying to talk him
into getting help as for that whole
running for president thing
the world would be a better place the
source added that the people close to
kanye want him to end his presidential
run
now before he does more damage to
himself
his brand and the family i've seen him
go through
a lot and he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart